[Applause]
it's been 30 years since billboard rain
hold on
song of the year was there a time in
your life that you was kind of exactly
on point you needed to hear that message
oh yeah yeah yeah no I was really in a
dark dark space when that lyric was
written I was really at a point in my
life where I felt like if I was I was at
a crossroads and I really felt like if I
didn't get my life together and stop
like doing drugs and you know had like a
really bad boyfriend at the time and I
just was in a lot of pain and I just
said if I don't if I don't change my
course I'm gonna be in a lot of trouble
so I knew that I was at a crossroads and
that I either had to like hold on for
one more day or just die I need it now
in this world in this time yeah who need
you know inspiration like this and songs
that can help get you through it you
know memories from the time it hit
number one
like did you splurge or did you do
something somewhere that was just like
time I heard it it was on my birthday on
the radio the first time I heard it hold
on was on my birthday a gift what a
great gift that was yeah yeah in
Tennessee an event I remember are the
details I swear to God I don't know I
was half on school I have no clue I know
I retain nothing oh God dates and stuff
like that is weird but just just just
knowing that we were so young when this
happened you know we were on the
whirlwind on tour we were just we didn't
know anything except we were a group
we'd love to sing and we just were
embraced by the world and we were
grateful for that you know part of hard
work
okay you just said something interesting
and I confess this when we were
rehearsing but I had no idea everyone
makes fun of me now I had no idea who
your parents were right until last night
why they keep talking about the Mamas
and the Papas in the beach fathers like
what does this have to do and I was like
no I just want you to know there's a
couple on your own marriage I was a man
it had nothing do you agree and I think
that that's kind of something cuz like
to grow up and I imagine that was very
hard I'm gauging and navigating that
with my kids I'm sure you have to as
well but being in the public eye having
parents so famous and trying to navigate
that and like what is normal and how do
I
there was no no no we also have a great
mom
Marilyn who's in the audience but she
was really she was really great at
keeping it you know steady and and being
real about things you know not
everything is normal or what is normal
and you know building our self-esteem
and as people and and showing us love
and that and now we instill that in our
kids yeah it's a boy it's a weird thing
to navigate but like I know so since
finding that out and I kind of read and
I felt like one of you was put to bed by
Sir Elton John huh and I was like yeah
what yeah what is your life oh yeah
doing it your house do a lullaby or
something I don't get it why don't know
he reminded me when I was just on the
talk with him a couple years ago that
don't you remember I put you to sleep
and I'm like what I know but I'm telling
everyone
he literally can I mean he just well he
wanted to buy dad's piano that he wrote
that dad wrote good vibrations on that
was all as you know solid piano a lot a
lot of memories there and he wanted this
piano he came over and he was probably
begging for it my mom said no but he I
guess I came downstairs when they were
chatting and doing that thing and he
said it's time to go back to bed and put
me in that mic my bed and that was a
Elton John play minute sleep okay then
it turns out of this story actually
isn't that it's the fact that your mom
was like no you can't have our piano
that panels mine now so so what are you
working on now you said you do a show a
month like everybody can find you do
instrument but what all I know you each
have kind of different things you're
into yeah so we do our one Sean month
and I've got a YouTube channel up right
now which I'm really super excited about
called California preach in yes and it's
all about okay I believe Jesus yeah and
so I talked a lot about to you yeah
[Applause]
California and trying to Phillips
California preaching Utah yeah I love
that passion is good spirituality is
great it is what are you up to man so
I'm I'm raising four boys whoa teenagers
so I will be giving you a lot of wine
you just start drinking but um I'm also
trying to develop my own personal care
products yeah line of personal care so
we're you really into all the healthy
things that happen with me I never cared
about me but once I had kids I was like
what's in this you feel responsible I
was always that way I was always like a
health nut you know wanted to know the
ingredients and stuff but yeah it's
important to me for sure it should be
important to all of us yeah yeah all
right yeah and let's see what else well
in terms of Wilson Phillips we just Rick
rerecorded hold on it's called hold on
today check it out on Spotify
and Jesus does for you what a pound
cakes and cheesecakes duck do for me yes
so I followed my heart and my vision I
created spirituality that's right Santa
I created Love Bites my carne it's a
it's a nationwide we're launching
grocery this year it's a dessert line of
gourmet dessert there's always a thing
with the weight and the whole image but
the truth is I'm not giving up sugar I'm
just gonna have a little bit and that's
the message I think it's healthy for me
personally most like look I struggle
with this I'm gonna allow a little bit
like Portia and try and stay you know
true the whole time because that's the
only way you'll be able to get there I
believe it's realistic yeah anyway I
love cake and I want to show everybody
the tape it's awesome
okay so Kelly it's the day before the
show the night before the show I made
peanut butter cakes and then I heard
that you didn't like peanut butter so I
rushed back in the kitchen and I made
you lemon cakes so here are your lemon
cakes for tomorrow those are low bites
and I made you I got some beautiful
frosting going some lemon marshmallow
glaze my glaze these puppies and bring
them into you for tomorrow yeah good go
ahead I've had five million of these
right now no but I was gonna say that if
you do have a sweet tooth I think that
this is amazing because the surface yeah
the bite size so it's like you're
getting it but it's not like excessive
they're like my children my problem is I
get this at home and I don't eat just
one right yeah yeah yeah oh my god lemon
and it's lemon marshmallow
yeah yeah lemon marshmallow oh my god we
are sisters find her mother I'm baking
together I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this